helping families during these difficult  times the pandemic did not stop  local leaders from making children happy  on easter  nevada democratic congressman stephen  horsford and clark county councilman  william mccurdy  organized a drive through easter basket  giveaway earlier today  the event was held at the walnut  recreation center and pearson community  center  city leaders say events like this are a  great opportunity to come together  and help members of the community  we want our families to know that we are  in this together truly  if you are a family or you know a family  member or a friend or a community member  who needs resources you can reach out to  clark county we have  rental assistance utility assistance and  if you are someone who is on the verge  of being without a home  let us know and we can help city leaders  were able to distribute over 300 baskets  for the children in the community which  is just wonderful